on était un couple heureux sans histoire
placide on demandait rien à personne et
tout à coup patatrac patatrac elle
achète le journal en allant au marché
et qu'est ce qu'on apprend voilà qu'à
nouveau la princesse anne et la tête un
match pourtant l'as monaco régnier a
levé les yeux au ciel devant tout le
monde
quand grâce lui a pris la main la même
semaine
ça va craquer cette logistique ça mais
craque mais nous dit pas ça dit pas ça
tu sais bien que ça te fait du mal déjà
la semaine dernière on avait eu une
alerte
le temps change était mis à brûler entre
le chat et farah diba nous ont ajouté de
rien on était à la campagne s'inventant
à paris j'achète le journal le chat de
points at-il oublié sera ya point
d'interrogation marabout de points
d'exclamation
alors moi je tiens le coup je suis un
homme c'est normal j'ai des réserves
mais ali fallait s'y attendre je pense
que le jour du sacre
farahi lui a dit merci en français et
lorsque tout le monde pouvait lire je
t'aime n'hésite pas parce qu'un gars qui
me regardent de travers à la cour que je
t'aimerai - tout le monde plusieurs
officiers
maintenant on est qu'ils y croient mais
j'y crois
déjà que soria s'est retrouvé sur le
carreau on n'était pas froid mais l'on
la 6e foire avec farah qui secoue est
revenu à l'emprunt sur toi il faut que
la vitre sur la plus forte et c'est
penser autre chose a dit elie bedos et
sophie daumier qu'est ce qui s'est passé
encore x et de la pareille quelques est
tel qu'un peu trop tirer sur la ficelle
et lui paye pas et ne vais pas être très
beau de l'intérieur s'inquiète eau et
leur chat se disant qu'ils avaient un
chien et bah c'était juste un mal à
égaler puis il prendra pour noël et la
pentecôte
enfin c'est pas les plus à plaindre
quand on pense à toutes les misères
regarde à buckingham ça fait deux
semaines que philippe pas adressé la
parole elisabeth tl courageuse elle
weill philippe daydé le début je te
l'avais dit je sais pas pourquoi je me
méfie lui je peux pas expliquer j'avais
pas le contact quand ils sont connus au
début on m'aurait demandé est ce qu
elisabeth à raison de l'épouser j'aurais
dit qu'ils vivent 1 5 mois à venir
montant lui au début il était chez pas
grec musclé avec quelque chose de
quelque chose de mouvement dans les yeux
la bouche une espèce que ça va ça va ça
va ça va me faire ma petite soupe aux
vêtements qui peuvent la fin je me force
mais qu'est ce que l'on avait mis peut
pas laisser mon amour quoi jackie
kennedy a souri au milliardaire paul
getty la peau beaucoup d'états pour me
faire plaisir mais non c'est pas mon
finalement jackie kennedy
or il a mieux aux 6 euros victime tout
petit